foreign
[Music]
there's only one way to find out
you and I we're not so different agent
Argyle
little help hold on
[Music]
phenomenal sweetie but
what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother Ellie it's called a
cop-out
hey there's a cat in there
oh my God you're Ellie freaking Conway
I'm such a fan oh yeah what is it you do
Espionage would you sign my book
here we go
I love this book
get up
come on
[Music]
who are these people real life spies why
would they care about me because you're
a goddamn fortune teller really
when you wrote a new book actually
happened and you kicked the Hornet's
Nest you didn't even know existed I'm in
some really big trouble Mom
[Music]
oh so now you're experimenting with
drugs I want all assets on them now I
need her to write the next chapter
[Music]
it's time for you to meet the real agent
Argyle
oh my God oh my God oh my God
thank you
foreign
[Music]